[Music]
Lee Moser thank you so much for joining
me how are you how's the last few days
been um very uh busy tired working from
Seven of
October uh not a lot of sleep very
worried but uh also um encouraging by
all the people that I see here with us
volunteering brother sister for Israel
yeah okay so right before we dive into
brothers and sisters for Israel take me
a little bit to you know what do you
actually do in the day today you know
outside of the war and um and then I I'd
love to understand you know what where
were you in the morning of October 7th
what where where did this meet you
everything that
happened so um I have a fund I'm a
managing partner at nventures um
together with my partner Roy and we
manage a fund and a venture studio and
we invest in early stage Israeli
startups this is what we do daily and on
7 of October um I actually woke up at
6:30 from a S siren I thought um you
know again another regular war from Gaza
and quickly I saw a picture from the
field of terrorists within Theon and the
kibu team and I woke up my husband who
is the founder of brothers and sisters
for Israel and brothers in arm and I was
like something going on which is not
right um and this is how we started our
day and in a few hours we understand
that that we issuing something that we
never issu like we never faced it before
in the history of Israel and uh started
to immediately organize what we do here
um and being worried about our families
and our friends that are out there in
the front in the north and in Gaza and
that's what happened incred incredible
and and so fast forward to today and
then we'll we'll sort of backtrack and
and and I'd love to hear the sort of the
story of how this whole thing came about
but what what's happening today with
brothers and sisters for Israel what is
this operation where are you right now
tell me a little bit about what's What's
Happening
Here sure uh so brother and sister for
Israel it's today the biggest civilian
organization it's actually started
during the protest uh for the
jurisdictionary Judiciary form and gain
like you know hundred of thousands of
followers and then When The War Began uh
we shifted everything that we do towards
supporting the IDF and the civilians no
matter what um and since we had tons of
followers it became the biggest
organization on ground today with 15,000
volunteers um we get probably 20,000
requests a day from civilians and from
soldiers from anything between evacu
them under Fire to giving them clothes
and food and support and psychological
support and anything um and it's really
it's basically we we fill the Gap until
the government will will will wake up
and will be able to move faster and then
they
will right right that that's incredible
okay so you know this massive operation
how many people are involved with it
Shine some light on the impact that this
has had already on
you know over the last 11
days so as I said it's about 15,000
daily volunteers uh we have about
thousand people at the headquarters um
divided to about 40 different
team people that evacuated and
responsible for the families people that
responsible for the psychology people
that responsible for the hid up and
missing there are 500 people working at
a tech headquarters near looking for any
kind of reference or clue of where those
people went right we we have about 200
something people in Gaza but still about
600 people that are missing SAA okay
great and so tell me a little bit about
what what is what is happening there
more tangibly on the graph so if you if
you were to walk into this to to the
place where you have a thousand people
headquarters what what would you see
what's happening
there the huge headquarter it's in a
high-tech uh co-working space called the
mixer um as I said my husband is the
founder of the organization he's also
giving the
interface um and it's it's actually
working as a tech company so you enter
you have the headquarters you have the
entire team you have logistic team you
have the fundraising team you have the
tech team responsible for the entire
data you have the TCH team deep deep
Tech open uh open net and also Dark Net
looking at the missing and kid people I
you have a huge Warehouse where you get
goods and you send them away and
basically this whole place is based on
all the data that we get from uh the
needs in the field right now both
Citizen and also so as I said it's uh
tens of thousands of requests a day and
we're flying to see what the needs buy
it distributed all by volunteers so this
is what we have today everything from
everything and now we're trying to
basically connect to the right
organization to the government and give
them the data that we have and and and
the support um and also you know
fundraising the resource that we need to
to be able to continue and be back and
be walk me through the progression of
the growth of this and how this emerged
to be now a 15,000 person organization
with a th000 people headquarters you
know walk me through from October 7th so
I I want people that weren't there that
weren't in Israel to really understand
how did the startup Nation come together
in this context that's I think it's a
really important piece of
this
smiling because I think the startup
nation became the volunteering Nation we
have has of H here the managing Partners
you know working here we have all the
big companies all but a lot of the tech
big companies are volunteering here we
have veterans from the army that war
commanders very high rank and also not
very high rank people from Logistics
people people just came people are
coming here and they're sing and they
want to V want to do something want to
be a part
day so they start taking initiative and
ownership of things that they know how
to do right you know how to buy things
from the US you start buying things for
the needs in the field and then people
start Gathering things around them so
for example me right I have a fun we
have great investors I immediately send
them an inlaw what we're do this is what
we need and then in two days I had a
team of 35 people fundraising for for
this whole organization from the entire
team of go sacks in Israel to different
fund managers and different people that
dos for many many the it was a little
bit spontane you know like in Israel
start of nation you have an idear start
running so this is really what happened
here um it's still uh its entire you
know growth and growing around every day
that should did you what what what
surprised you in what happened you know
if you started looking now back into
these 11 days what what were some
moments that perhaps took you by
surprise or that shined light on on sort
of new realizations of where we're
at the magnitude of the
event and people that are the mag of
being the event go from like the
disaster that we had
here
really sad it's it's it's it's like the
hor entire family's babies
were
being
ra let
you know the most terrible stories in
the world but also the magnitude of
people that are
volun so if are coming together doesn't
matter left right for the 12 years um
and trying to make sure that we support
our soldiers and we support our people
no matter what so this is this is your
it's
your from an organizational perspective
growing to a logistical arm and an
operation of the magnitude that that you
have how how does that take place I mean
what do you have to do to get you know
what what are the elements that need to
come together so that a group of people
um a huge group of people can come
together the way that it did now people
are basically giving everything that
they can they working 247 so I think
first is devotion second is
professionalism you do what you good at
right so I guess people are coming and
say I'm good at that I can manage that I
can grow into that um and this is what
you need as a beginning as the
organization will involve evolve and we
will become into a so you know event us
all of us we need to go back through a
daily routine and they would be the
professional team to end up with it it's
probably more and so when you have now
obviously this is a dynamic situation
and the we we every day that goes by we
learn more about the conflict and the
war and and the needs of our soldiers
and the needs of what's happening so
when new needs arise and when there's
new opportunities to support and to help
what how does this now trickle down to
an operation that you're able to within
ours potentially provide your support in
a meaningful way what what what happens
from sort of a leadership or management
perspective that allows you to be this
Dynamic and this Nimble because I think
that's a really a really unique ability
that you've created
here it is but I think it's also what
you basically mentioned it the the
beginning of being a start of Nations
and and and being a part of this country
that create great Solutions and great
technology that are disrupting the world
is also the initiative or of stepping
forward and doing what it needs to be
done no matter what and this is what you
see here so it's a matter of culture I'm
going to step forward and I'm going to
take an initiative and I'm going to take
a
responsibility okay to taking care of
six ,000 families see we have 40 people
in between taking care of refugees or
it's taking care of the data or it's
taking care of the fundraise or it's
taking care of managing this
organization people are step stepping
forward as they do in their private life
and in the be SE sector and it's
something that I think is very unique to
Israel okay tell me a little bit about
your own experience so you're managing a
fund in the day today you're investing
in startups all of a sudden you find
yourself immersed in this um
yes your husband is also he's been
running but but you're you're fully in
and I'm seeing it 247 from your end what
do this been like for you per on a
personal
level first of all it's very hard I have
two young daughters five and free and
they're home with you know my parents
and babysitter and I miss them a lot but
I know I have a sense of mission and I
need to be here can I have a great
partner and an amazing team that are
affording me and doing need the B he do
that as e which I know that my business
is is okay and we're supporting our
Founders and this is a whole entire
operation you know probably like half of
our Founders are in the front we want to
support and want to make sure that
nothing is dropping and whatever we can
do uh you know from a CTO perspective
that we have too to credentials that we
have a CFO we do that and I really trust
my te you know we've been running for 3
and half years um they have my back and
I can't wait to go back to the office
and sit with them and do investment for
me and and actually what we do now we
basically want to invest more money into
estate startup to fuel the economy and
make sure that we also do good by our
industry so this is something that we're
learning right now just want to say that
we decided also to support our ecosystem
so we going to invest in in our studio
in five different startups and the next
two three weeks um
$200,000 in each very early stage
company to make sure that our ecosystem
and our culture and what you part of for
the past few years is keep on going and
and being supported by the the invest
investor and investment side incredible
so if somebody looking from the outside
what is perhaps the most important thing
that they need to know about your work
with a brothers and sisters for Israel
and and what's been happening here over
the 11 days what is sort of the
underlying and the underlying you know
sort of understanding that you that they
should walk away with um
2,700 family been rescued from uh areas
Under Fire elderly women with kids that
their husband are either dead or in the
Army
um five Logistics Warehouse seed from
resonation and from sted we start buying
for the field 150,000 meals for refugees
and people that are evacuated for
soldiers 40,000 ceramic vests that we
bought and distributed through the Army
um to our soldiers on ground um and now
four different civil Aid initiatives
that we're um starting to build from the
field incredible great well Lee thank
you uh so much I know you're terribly
busy I know you're right outside of
where the soul operation is taking place
H and so thank you for thank you for
spend this time and and thank you for
all the amazing work that you're doing I
know you haven't slept in in in 11 days
and uh praying all for better days thank
you very
[Laughter]
much